[Music]
or even providing interactive quality education
is accessible to everyone and
will be weak anywhere and
anytime diagnosing lung diseases
through open
web-based technology is freely accessible
[Music]
and if we can  eliminate gender bias
in written texts create
new energy-efficient materials
the development of
socially responsible artificial intelligence
for the benefit of all is at the heart
of bill's mission to the community ya
for humanity is composed of researchers and
of stakeholders with diverse skills
who wish to enrich the perspective
that humans have of AI for having
signed responsible it is necessary to bring together
civil society actors from the
academic world and public decision-makers
from elsewhere a thousand souls has contributed to
the  elaboration of the
montreal declaration which is an ethical framework for
the responsible development
of artificial intelligence
[Music  e]
together we want to address
major social issues reduce
equality and protect the planet
[Music]